So when I was born in China
in the early 1980s,
my country was still a place of scarcity.
We lived on rationed food,
cooked from communal kitchens
and even in Beijing had three nights
of blackouts every week.
I remember reading poems
with my father by candlelight.
A special memory from times
when Chinese people had little.
And fast forward three decades,
China has turned
into a country of abundance,
especially when it comes
to technological power.
From high tech to business tech
to everyday tech,
there isn't anything you can't find,
only things you can't imagine.
I can buy a can of Coke
by scanning my face.
A few years ago,
I called for toothpaste
from my hotel room,
and it was delivered to me by a robot.
I've seen people live in remote Tibetan
mountains blast off cool music
with Walkmans powered by solar cells
and Chinese solar technology
light up homes for African kids
who used to study by candlelight,
just like me when I was growing up.
So this striking swell
of innovation happened
even though China remains
a developing country,
with just a little more
than 10,000 dollars of per capita GDP.
So today I want to offer you
a different lens to look through,
one that shows a unique model
that has fostered innovation
and technological growth.
Now the system is far from perfect.
And like you, I worry about the rising
tensions of a tech race and beyond.
But I also believe
that, as in any relationship,
a better understanding of each other
is going to help us more likely to find
common goals to work on
rather than a downward
spiral that harms all.
So I'm an economist,
straddling multiple worlds,
as it turns out.
One foot in London,
where I do my research.
And one foot in China,
where I spend time with my family
and also do a bit of work.
And if I had a third foot,
it would be in the US,
where I was educated.
So I can totally see why
there's so much misunderstanding
and incomprehension
about this megacountry
that has defied conventional wisdom.
So let's start out
with how China's innovating.
Now, innovation isn't just
about inventing the next new thing,
like the iPhone or 3D printing
or sending people to Mars.
Technologies that go from zero to one.
It could be new applications,
business models,
better processes that lower costs.
These one-to-n innovations
are just as important.
Whatever makes us leaner,
cleaner and more productive,
all count.
So TikTok might not be
the first short-video app,
but it has garnered more
than a billion users around the world.
The Chinese EV company, BYD,
didn't make the first prototype.
But compared to Tesla's price point,
the 15,000-dollars EV cabs that I've taken
with half a million kilometers of range
can meaningfully lead to lower
emissions and mass adoption.
And in the same way,
Chinese mobile phones
might not be as revolutionary as iPhone,
but in African countries,
their market share is well over half.
So this actually solves one big problem
for developing countries,
which is the lack of access to suitable
technologies that they can actually use.
And even if China doesn't do many
zero-to-one technologies yet --
at least not yet --
it doesn't mean that it can't
master high tech, right?
It conducted the first quantum video call,
and it launched the first drone
that can carry a passenger in air.
So let's go behind the scenes.
Now, yes, many of you would say
China's got money, markets, talent
and troves of data, which is so critical
in this information age.
But it wasn't just that.
Part of the success was also
a "whole nation" approach,
or what they call a "juguo" system.
So turning an idea or scientific discovery
into commercial success
requires an innovation ecosystem.
The collaboration of universities,
national labs and industries,
not to mention enormous amount of funding
that covers long
and uncertain investment cycles.
Now, many of you might think
that groundbreaking technologies
are the products of stars,
the likes of Steve Jobs or Elon Musks.
But every time you use the internet,
the GPS or yell at your Alexa,
you have the US government to thank for.
We often forget that the Apollo program,
the Manhattan Project,
even Japan's rise
to semiconductor stardom,
were all horizontal systems
with critical state backing.
Now, China's "juguo" system
is an entire nation
behind one strategic goal.
Mobilizing national resources,
casting the net wide,
not tallying costs.
And it’s the same system
that’s used to reap
as many Olympic gold medals as possible.
And so thanks to this ecosystem,
China became the largest consumer
and producers of EVs
in less than a decade.
With more cars sold there
than in the rest of the world
combined in 2020.
Now in the West,
we often talk about "nudging" consumers
to make better choices.
But in China, mass adoption of next-gen
transportation happened like that.
Well, in part thanks to the state
rolling out four million charging stations
around the country,
coordinating supply chains
from battery makers to control systems
and manufacturers.
Today, there are 140,000 chargers
in the US in the entire country.
So that is kind of,
the "whole nation" approach.
But that's not actually
the story I want to tell you.
There's an even more nuanced story
that happens on the ground.
We call it the “mayor economy,”
and it's a decentralized economic model
that galvanizes creativity
from the ground up.
And contrary to popular perception,
it isn't a centralized approach
dominated by an almighty state.
And so here's how it works.
So Nio is one of the top three
EV companies in China.
Its cars are driven everywhere
on the streets of Beijing and Shanghai.
Now, two years after it was listed
on Nasdaq in 2018,
it was on the verge of bankruptcy.
Now, at this point,
the local government of Hefei,
a small town in eastern China
with five million people,
convinced it to move
its headquarters there.
The local government
injected a billion dollars
in exchange for a 25-percent stake,
arranged more loans for the company
and most importantly,
organized an entire
supply chain around Nio.
It took only a year before Nio's
production grew by 81 percent,
its market cap went
from four to 100 billion dollars.
And the local government of Hefei
cashed out within a year,
and Nio's life was saved.
And so for every local
government behind a Nio,
there's another mayor behind a competitor.
And there are literally hundreds
of EV companies vying for survival
in ruthless competition.
So,
if you are actually
a promising tech company,
local governments
will move mountains to help.
Remove red tape, check.
Find you more financing, check.
Get a job for your spouse, check.
Piece of cake.
They are a one-stop shop,
as they like to call themselves.
Now in the vigorous bid
for Amazon's second headquarters,
there were some creative offers.
One state sent a giant cactus as a gift.
Another state offered
to rename a town Amazon.
But it basically came to some tax breaks,
not quite like what the Chinese
mayors had to offer.
But of course,
the US government is no stranger
to supporting big-shot companies
like SpaceX and Tesla,
offering billions in benefits.
But in China, it's really this marriage
between hyper-charged local officials
and intrepid entrepreneurs of all ilk
that is at the heart of its model.
And here's why.
So the local government of Hefei,
the one that made a killing with Nio,
well, it wasn't just after
the return on investment, per se.
But it was by luring companies like Nio
that it’s looking to create
a mini Silicon Valley of sorts.
An industrial clutter, a talent pool,
a flourishing retail and service industry
that gets them more jobs,
more tax revenues.
And guess what?
Even the real estate and land they own
are suddenly worth more,
all because of the economics
of agglomeration and multiplier effects,
because the local mayors are actually
an equity stakeholder of the entire city.
So in sum,
it's this political centralization
and economic decentralization
that is actually a simple
representation of China's model.
It's the same model used to urbanize,
to grow and now to innovate.
Now, for all of its successes,
there were huge costs, I admit.
Waste left in the wake,
inefficient investments, wrong bets.
Now, some of these challenges
are being addressed, thankfully,
like environmental degradation,
but there are others that remain
in urgent need of fixing.
So I'm not suggesting
that there's some universal recipe
or that it's perfect
or that it can be easily replicated.
But what we do know is that there's more
than one way of making things work.
And recognizing that there is
some wisdom to China's approach
doesn't mean endorsing all of it.
But I guess there's something
to learn from each other.
And for one,
China didn't sit on the tarmac
waiting for a technological takeoff.
Instead, it was the big push
from the ground up.
So I came to the US
as an exchange student in 1997,
and I was mesmerized.
I saw enormous possibility
between the East and the West,
as they competed, collaborated
and spurred each other forward.
I still believe in this,
even though frost has set in
and there may be chill
in the air for some time
between the two largest
economies in the world.
Some may fear China's
juggernaut innovation.
Some may not like competition,
which is rarely comfortable.
But having someone in your rearview mirror
helps you keep up the pace.
Japan's technological rise in the 1980s
pushed the US to overhaul
its innovation system
and regain the lead in the 1990s.
The US subsequently
did the same for Japan,
and as a result, we all have cheaper
and better products.
Today, Chinese EV company BYD is pushing
Tesla to new heights and vice versa.
Tesla opted for a Chinese battery maker,
which is pushing the German government
to do more in that space.
And it's that mutual learning
and constant threat of being overtaken
that pushes the technology frontier
further and beyond.
But one thing's for sure, true,
it just doesn't happen
in geographical isolation.
So ...
I’ve come here, and I imagine
the possibilities
between the two countries,
and I understand that there are
national security concerns
that countries will have to respect.
But not everything
is about national security.
The trillion dollars or more at stake
with the economic disengagement
between the two largest countries
can do so much as eradicate
malaria, end world hunger,
conserve biodiversity and more.
So let's not forget that there are
more sacred things in life.
Such as a brighter future
for our children and a cleaner Earth.
Let's not forget
that in the developing world,
there's still so much unnecessary misery.
And that its people also have the right
to enjoy the dignity in life
as those who are more fortunate.
And so for all of this to happen,
it seems to me
that what we ultimately need
is the cheapest and best technologies,
rather than worry
about where they come from
or who will dominate.
Thank you.
(Applause)